welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Mike McGovern an assistant professor
of anthropology at Yale University
professor McGovern is a political
anthropologist who works in West Africa
and uses a variety of sources from
kinship idioms to the aesthetics of
state-sponsored folklore to try to
understand post-colonial states within
the arc of longer historical
trajectories today we'll talk with him
about his first book entitled making war
in Cote d'Ivoire
welcome professor McGovern thanks for
having me let's begin by talking about
your book give us an overview well it's
about making war as a process not as an
event which is meant to put the process
of war making into the the broader
context of peacetime politics and so not
to see it as a rupture from peacetime
but actually see the ways in which it's
connected with the way that people do
politics in a particular place during
war and during peace and what are some
of the questions you address in your
book well you may have read or seen in
the news that Cote d'Ivoire is supposed
to be a conflict that's about religion
muslims and christians or about ethnic
groups and one of the first things i try
to do in the book is to challenge that
approach to seeing the the root causes
of the conflict in fact it's got a much
more complex set of causes which are
largely political economic ones
there's a lot of money at stake and in
fact this situation that we have in Cote
d'Ivoire which is kind of one of neither
peace nor war is very lucrative because
in having a state of emergency in the
country one can justify all kinds of
actions that allow for illegal economic
activities to take place and what drew
you to this part of the world what gave
you the idea
for the book well I was a Peace Corps
volunteer in Guinea the neighbouring
country in 1989 for two years and I was
right on the border with Liberia and
Cote d'Ivoire
and during the time I was there the war
the civil war in Liberia began and
refugees started pouring into Guinea
from there and a little bit later I went
to Cote d'Ivoire for the first time and
it was interesting because both
countries Guinea and Cote d'Ivoire had
French colonial legacies they spoke
French as a national language a lot of
things were the same and yet the
national cultures were radically
different Guinea had been a socialist
country had rejected France totally in
1958
whereas Cote d'Ivoire had actually sort
of embraced its relationship with France
even after independence the Guinean said
well the alarians look down on us
because we're poorer than they are now
but we'll see over time whether or not
the chickens come home to roost as it
were and in fact that's what happened
you know about 15 20 years later and
part of my interest is trying to
understand why that happened and how did
you do the research
what was your methodology well as I said
I had lived for a long time in Guinea
and I did my PhD dissertation on Guinea
again right near the border with Cote
d'Ivoire that research which sort of
informs my understanding of avoir Ian's
rural realities was very much done in
little villages no electricity or
running water no cell phones or Internet
and the ways that people actually made a
living as rice farmers and farming cash
crops like cocoa and coffee and the way
that they related to the the bigger
state in Guinea as in Cote d'Ivoire
there were inter-ethnic tensions having
to do with land ownership and land use
but things played out quite quite
differently in Cote d'Ivoire
so when I began going to Cote d'Ivoire
one of the things I looked at was you
know why those differences took place
later after doing my PhD I was the West
Africa director of International Crisis
Group and during that time I was
actually doing active research in Cote
d'Ivoire for about a two and a half year
period on and off I would go there I
would also go to some of the other
countries in West Africa and that's
where I did most of the research a lot
of it was in Abidjan with political
elites because of the work I was doing I
came to know people like Laurent Gbagbo
the president or ex president depending
how you see it and unless on watch era
who was elected in in November as
president but hasn't really taken power
yet as well as a lot of the other key
actors I also got to know people like
the young Patriots this movement of
young men who kind of controlled the
streets at certain moments and have very
kind of a militant violent street
politics in favor of Laurent Gbagbo so
my research was kind of mixed between
this rural village based research and
then this research with political elites
and also with ordinary people in the the
main city so basically it's talking to
people mainly talking to people but of
course I I don't I didn't do
quantitative research of my own but I
use other people's quantitative research
for instance on the economy around cocoa
as you may know 40% of the world's cocoa
comes from Cote d'Ivoire so if you had a
chocolate bar today it was probably made
with of Lorien cocoa there are calls
right now to to have an embargo on avoir
en cocoa in order to force Laurent
Gbagbo out of power so I use other
people's quantitative research to
supplement my own okay is it a dangerous
place today to be in
danger is always a relative thing I've
done research in in Liberia right after
the end of the Civil War which was much
more dangerous you know as we saw with
the bombing in the airport in Moscow
yesterday it can be dangerous to be in
lots of places but it's it's not a
politically stable country right now
particularly in the wake of these
elections from November 2010 there's
been a lot of street violence there have
been people getting disappeared and
there have been extrajudicial killings
at least allegations of torture so it's
it's an unsettled place to say the least
let's talk about some of the findings in
your book well one of the findings as I
said is that it can be very lucrative to
have this unstable situation of neither
war nor peace but one of my other
interests is how do you get to a
situation where a war seems to be taking
off and and ready to happen and yet it
never completely takes off so it's a
kind of a frozen conflict as some people
would say what are the reasons why you
get in Rwanda for instance a conflict
that has inter-ethnic conflict overtones
that really becomes a genocide where's
in Cote d'Ivoire it never gets to that
level or it never gets the level of a
full-blown war you have isolated
massacres and then long periods of peace
in between and one of the things that I
suggest is that the actors for instance
at the village level of village chief
who might be interested in reclaiming
land that had been sold to people who
came from the outside a youth politics
leader like these young Patriots who's a
university graduate but has gotten sort
of routed toward a kind of a mafia like
illegal economy because there are no
jobs for university graduates and in
Cote d'Ivoire and a political elite like
the people who are at the head
the parties they have very different
incentives interests and the part of the
question is whether or not those
interests ever get aligned with one
another and so part of what I look at in
cote ivoire is why the alignment failed
to happen to bring all of these people's
interests together so that they would
all push in one direction what you see
is actually people pulling in opposite
direction and what are the parties who
are involved in in the conflict well one
of the most interesting groups is these
young Patriots and a lot of them in fact
the two main protagonists at the youth
level are a man called Charlie geudae
who is known as the general of the
streets and he's the head of the young
Patriots and then on the opposite side
Guillaume Soho who was the
secretary-general of the new the new
forces the force nouvelle who was the
the group of X rebels controlling the
north
now Charlie geudae is a minister in the
Gbagbo government and gihon soro is
prime minister of the opposed what at
our government but it so happens that
these guys used to be roommates
they were both English majors at the
university of Abidjan they were both
leaders of the student union one after
the other during this period when the
student union was becoming criminalized
and was basically doing things like
controlling the stock of dormitories for
university students and charging people
a premium if they wanted to get access
to them and so they rather than studying
and rather than pursuing their degrees
they actually got involved in this kind
of violent student politics that had
much more to do with economics than with
studying and they themselves talked
about the way in which this was their
training for politics in kochevar they
see the people ahead of them the
generation that includes what era and
bug
as being the people who blocked their
normal progress through education toward
ordinary jobs but by the same time by
the same token those older people are
their patrons and the people who have
opened up these other possibilities
through the kind of route of political
violence so what do you foresee
happening do you think there will become
a full blown out war do you think things
will settle down with a new
administration perhaps what do you think
the future holds it's it's very tricky
there are two administrations there's
two parallel governments right now and
you have the West African regional body
threatening to intervene by military
force if Gbagbo doesn't leave and at the
same time you have this threat of
sanctions and embargoes on tiwari and
cocoa which are going to hurt ordinary
of lorian's as well as the elites so in
the the situation has become much more
fragile in the last three months I would
have said three months ago very unlikely
that you would have a full-blown war but
at this point I think it can't be ruled
out I say conclusions in your book well
the conclusion is largely that we have
to look at violence in its longer-term
historical context to understand the
reasons why people resort to it whether
they be young people or political elites
and in understanding that we might have
a better understanding of how one might
intervene from the outside to help stave
off the possibility of a full-blown war
in the process of doing the research did
you come across any particular
difficulties or surprises
well difficulties I you know yes of
course yeah and you know at a certain
point I was arrested by these young
Patriots along with the various security
forces at just a roadblock in
the western part of the country and what
happened well I my colleague and I were
held for about 12 hours interrogated
brought to another town where we were
interrogated again by the head of the
military base there who decided finally
to let us go but tell us to be gone by
by the next morning leave the country
leave that region of the of the country
and go to the capital is there any
physical violence were you in fear of
your life well yeah I mean people were
pointing guns at us but that we were it
harmed in any way
so does that color your your perspective
of the country in terms of you know how
you portray it in your writing well I
would say this when I first had a kind
of a nasty interaction with the Iranian
security forces this is about 10 years
ago I rolled into the town that I was
trying to get to and got there very late
at night found a restaurant that was
open hadn't eaten and I started
complaining to the waiter and he said
well you know I'm from the next country
over I'm from burkina faso
and all that's happened since the
soldiers took over in a coup d'etat this
was around 2000 he said all that's
changed since the soldiers took over is
that they now do the same things to
people like you that they've been doing
to me for a decade or more and it gave
me a real insight into the kinds of
grievances that a lot of people in Cote
d'Ivoire had and I've seen in shared
taxis and so forth lots of people get
hassled right up to the point of having
their papers their identity papers taken
away from them where the soldiers said
you either pay us a lot of money or you
don't get them back Wow
so in the events cote ivoire does go to
war what do you think will happen well
who do you think will win honestly I
want to yeah it's not it's not a win
situation for anybody what we've seen so
far is that it's civilians who've come
in for the worst abuse by all sides so
it's not if anybody wins it's a few
political elites who get a bigger piece
of the economic pie but for Cote
d'Ivoire as a country it's not a winning
bargain by any means well I guess we'll
see what the future holds for that
country thank you very much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work thanks for having me for more
information about Professor McGovern and
his work please visit our website at
yale.edu backslash McMillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the McMillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty McMillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale